well the thing is we all have a dance
move we break out right so at we were
asking the audience about kind of their
signature dance moves so yes I see
cameras turning around yeah really
giggles everyone yeah okay okay let's do
this yeah
where's Lisa oh there's Lisa now Lisa
has two moves so tell us the names of
your two moves
um the sprinkler and the lawn mower the
sprinkler of a lawn mower okay
definitely in the gardening
okay do you want to step out into the
the aisle there will pay a bit of music
and we can see the sprinkler first and
then what is it the lawn mower yeah the
lawn mower okay okay so play a bit of
music here we go
[Applause]
yeah but what Mesa burger
next up
no not a riding mower no yeah that's
vent that's vintage
just fancy you've changed
yes what's she doing is it dad where's
Caleb
oh there's Caleb Caleb's is really
specific and what's what's owed it it's
all spit the gum good fatty Caleb cuz
who knew I was coming to you next
we're doing that dancing item there told
me about
in addition Hague or if your friend is
holding her
okay I respect your humility because you
decided there's no way you could
possibly do this dance move and chew gum
at the same I respect that humility he
wants to nail the dance move okay let's
hear it that me these complicated okay
okay Caleb tonight Kaden will be
attempting the daddy boxed up with the
Robert De Niro that's a lot that's a lot
okay okay time out into the out into the
aisle let's that's easy
okay okay let's start the music I need a
something
oh wait needs a consult the music just
to get just get the face the face going
okay man okay
[Applause]
[Applause]
you can't he is so cold he is so pulled
doing can't don't ye chew gum he can't
do oh sorry
that's the best bit she says open it
back to him
[Applause]
Wow oh dear
where's Suzie Suzie oh there's Suzie
hiya
what could M yours now shopping cart she
remembered well done can you do it in
your seat or do you need to come out of
night I need to come out opilio shitty
talk about letter auntie need space to
need space okay yeah good it's good
alright okay
basically the shopping cart here we go
I'll go
[Applause]
what am i doing okay okay that's all you
grab and is you pushing the same cart
okay
[Applause]
[Applause]
it may be changing
we've got photographic proof of you
liking Baker yes they get a beanie he
was like sure conversation went but they
sort of walked me over to him and he
said oh hi nice to meet you and I said
nice to meet you